Okay.
Yeah.
The Joe Rogan experience
[inaudible]
brothers and sisters,
lovers in children,
Brian Red Van and Eddie
Bravo or in the building.
Hello.
Much respect to the Korean Zombie.
Eddie Bravo was wearing
a Korean Zombie shirt.
And what this means for you,
non MMA people.
There's a guy named Chan,
some Junge who's the,
they call them the Korean Zombie.
That's his nickname.
And this weekend on a Saturday night
at the UFC against Leonard Garcia,
he pulled off the first
twister ever in the UFC.
And the significance of
course is at Eddie Bravo.
Our guests today actually
invented the twister.
I didn't invent it.
Well,
you invented the rest.
Set up the setup.
The setups.
Yes.
The finishing move.
No,
when you called the rustling mode,
but people used to finish
people within wrestling.
You can,
but did they do it your way
with the s grip on the forehead?
I thought that was all like your,
your uh,
innovation to turn into submission.
Uh,
no,
no.
People were cranky.
I don't know if they were cranking
and exactly the way I crank it,
but I'm pretty sure,
um,
you seen other people get submitted with
it before you ever started doing it?
We would like to,
in high school,
I wrestled a couple of years and then I
wrestled in Santa Anna High and in ninth
grade a guy named Jesse
Barrios and another guy,
his buddy is the one who showed me,
I can't remember his name,
I couldn't even remember it from my book,
but Jesse Barrios is his friend,
Santa Ana high school in 1985.
If anybody out there is from that,
there's Jesse Barrios friend,
the other leg rider on
that wrestling team.
Fuck,
I don't know what his name was.
Anyways,
he showed it to me and both
of those and in wrestling,
leg riding is for weak people.
And all that means is,
is,
uh,
we need,
we're so weak,
we need to use our legs a lot more than
the big strong dudes who are wrestling
and,
and hitting the weights and
had big chest and shoulders.
Those guys really didn't rely on their
legs as much as the weak guys like me.
I would skip Russ,
uh,
weightlifting practice.
I was in the back of the house hiding.
I was,
I was weak.
Even back then.
I was a terrible athlete.
I've never been a great athlete,
so I had to rely on using my legs.
And I thought,
you know,
they came to me,
Jesse came to me and I go,
dude,
you'll be perfect for this.
You know,
cause they knew I would just get out,
just get smashed if I try
to go heads up with people.
So it's a pending move in
that I learned in wrestling.
And um,
I got,
I got pretty good at it.
I would,
that was my shit.
Even in high school.
That was my,
that was the thing I always tried.
I got some cool ass stories
that maybe one day I'll,
I'll,
uh,
I'll talk about them,
but I have some cool wrestling stories.
But anyways,
I sucked at wrestling.
I only had one take
down two fucking years.
I sucked.
So I just totally relied on
leg riding and and using the,
it's actually called the guillotine.
It's actually not called the twister,
it's called the guillotine,
but when I started doing it in Jujitsu,
Higgin Machado and John John Machado
would just call it the twister because the
guillotine already existed.
There's a lot of people out there that
that think that I'd like took this
wrestling move and I said,
I'm going to try to fool the world and
change the name and say I invented it.
There's thousands of people
that think that it's hilarious.
In my books from day one,
I I,
it was good people to hold on.
So you're being a little bit modest
because you invented all these setups and
turned it into a very
high percentage finish.
Yeah.
You did a lot of signups from a lot
of different places where it became,
I'm doing,
none of that stuff existed,
but this is the transition.
So
I ended up quitting wrestling.
The work,
the work,
the work will,
the work ethic,
you need to be a good wrestler or
something that is just not in my body.
Chemistry.
I was not made to work
really hard physically I,
I just,
I hated work.
Regular jobs.
I knew that's why it was
all about rock stardom or,
or playing football.
It was a,
I just want her to be like a famous dude
who just played for a living and got
paid and it was a fucking
adored by everybody.
That's what I wanted.
I didn't want to work.
I hate it.
Of course.
Who doesn't want,
Oh my God,
what worked like actually
like killed me inside.
So it drove my artistic side.
So once I realized that
Mexicans don't play football,
I'm like,
oh my God,
I was in ninth grade and I was the
slowest motherfucker out there.
And,
and the owl,
that was it.
You know,
I had these dreams of playing football
or make it an a music that football was
crushed in ninth grade.
Once everyone starts to grow,
you know what?
Junior,
all American and pee wee football,
that's fucked up.
I played defensive lineman and
middle linebacker in football.
I actually thought I was going to be a
defensive lineman and a middle linebacker
because when you're eight and year nine,
everyone is the same size.
And you know,
you did some brainwashing going on
that really thought I was going to be a
football player.
I really thought I was
until ninth grade shit.
Oh Man.
When,
when I was in sixth grade,
I was supposed to make the football
team because in my neighborhood,
in my neighborhood,
uh,
I was pretty,
I was a pretty good football player
around Mexicans from like a really poor
neighborhood.
I was pretty bad ass.
But when you go to school,
when you go,
when I went to sixth
grade and then junior,
all American,
when you know,
football,
peewee football was pretty,
I was pretty good.
But once people start
growing and start changing,
and sixth grade,
I went to sixth grade and I
didn't make the football team.
They cut me off far from the,
the,
I was so embarrassing,
but it was flag football.
It wasn't tackle.
So in my head I'm like,
wait until ninth grade
when I get the high school,
I'm gonna play some tap cause I'm going
to show you what the fuck's going on.
So that's what I was thinking that I go,
fuck this year fucks it's sixth grade.
So seventh grade I
transferred myself to a far,
uh,
a school far away that I only went to,
cause there's another story,
there's more stories where I was
driven away from my junior high school.
So I went to another school.
I tried out for the football
team in the seventh grade.
I got good again,
but it was flag football.
But I was so embarrassed that I told,
I told my friends growing up,
all my kids,
I told him that,
yeah,
I made the team second string quarterback,
but you know what?
I got in a fight.
So they had to cut me.
Man,
it sucks.
I don't,
the kids that I grew up with
thought I made the team,
but I got cut because I
got in a fight with a dude.
I kept that going.
I was so embarrassed that
I didn't make the team.
I was so embarrassed and
then in the eighth grade,
one of,
one of my,
the guys that I grew up with winter,
that school too,
he made the team.
He was awesome.
I didn't make the team again.
He never brought up the fact
that he never asked anybody,
didn't even make the team last year.
That never got brought up.
They never humiliated me.
Maybe they were talking behind
my back like like I don't know.
No one ever brought it up,
but I did lie about it and
I'm coming clean with it now.
I totally lied about it.
Don't you think for dudes
that competition like that,
any kind of competition,
whether it's football or
wrestling or anything,
is it so important for kids and they're
growing up to know how hard it is?
If you really want to
get good at something,
oh yeah.
You got like Mexicans.
Listen,
if you're Mexican and you think
you're going to be a football player,
look at reality.
Listen to me.
Liquor reality.
There's not that very,
there's one Mexican and
he plays quarterback.
You think you're going to be him?
Get Out,
get out of football,
get that shit out of your
head if you're Mexican,
unless you got some tall
motherfuckers and your family.
There's a couple of Mexicans out there
but is easily made it as a four maybe.
Maybe you think maybe it's do with that.
There's a lot more than
just being an athlete.
Everybody's an athlete and a football.
You've got to have some serious
skills and serious magic.
He could've just been a
really strong athletic guy.
Look at Matt Mitch Realm and strong and
athletic match material is a fucking
athlete.
You know,
he didn't.
So do you think that if those
guys came over to the UFC,
those super athletes,
so it's NFL dudes.
Do you think that like that's what we're
seeing with like John Jones because
that's the talk that,
you know,
Jon Jones has two brothers I believe,
that are playing football right now.
I mean we've sat,
it's incredible.
I mean he's a,
Jon Jones is,
he's a super athlete and there's,
there's dudes that are super athletes
that are in maybe other sports and we're
starting to see in the UFC.
That's like a big topic of discussion.
Like what,
how much of a difference does
like serious athleticism make?
It makes a huge,
Jon Jones has been a fucking doing,
he's been doing mixed martial
arts for only three years.
Before that he was a wrestler.
I mean that's incredible.
We're going to,
you know what,
it's already happened in boxing.
Just look at what happened with
boxing culturally look what happened.
It's interesting though
that football and it's,
I guess it's just where
the money is that the,
the high money ones like
football and basketball,
they get the best athletes.
Yes.
I mean even though the UFC
has been around now for,
you know,
since [inaudible] 93 it's not
been like a real accepted,
you know,
a mainstream thing,
but for like the last five or six years,
right,
when you say yes,
yes.
You know,
it's the super athletes that start Jujitsu
early wrestling their whole lives and
striking early.
They put it together like
the roof old brothers.
Yes.
It's the best athletes that start
off like the raw Ruffo brothers,
you know?
I mean,
it's some,
some people can start off with Jujitsu
and wrestling and striking early and
achieve so much physically from it,
but still they weren't
born with the athleticism.
You know what I mean?
You've got to be a natural.
It's got to all come together.
You've got to have all the pieces together
to make it in the big sports that we
see today.
And they're like foot.
You can't start,
start playing football when
you're 22 and make the NFL.
If you do that.
It may have happened once or twice.
Some African Guy,
I don't know.
It may have happened.
Why not?
I mean,
uh,
you know,
one of them [inaudible] guys that started
playing basketball for 18 months and
he's in the NBA.
You know what I'm saying?
Every now and then you get those freaks.
But generally 98% of the time,
look at what's going
on with all the sports.
They just go and find that dude and say,
hey,
you want to play basketball?
I don't even know.
I'm just making it one of those goods.
What are those dudes?
I'm sure minuit bowl at a combi.
Mutombo.
I can't even say his name,
but one of those dudes I'm sure
started playing basketball late.
Do you imagine what it must
be like living like nuke ball?
It's like you're living in doll houses.
Everywhere you go.
They're dollhouses.
Everyone's building is built for a dolls.
You have to hunch everywhere you go.
Mad worked nights not naturally for girls,
for girls,
taller guys.
Naturally the taller you are,
the more attractive you on it naturally,
but what,
what exactly what size?
Six eight,
six,
seven.
Does it become a turnoff to girls because
there must be a turn off point or are
they turned on by guys that are
seven foot three there's a guy,
a girl look at a guy seven foot
three and it's totally attracted him.
He's seven foot three so rare.
I love so much.
Or is it like,
hmm,
that's too tall.
I don't like of that tos.
Ridiculous.
You know what I mean?
What is it?
Well,
they would also worry,
I think evolutionarily about that.
Is this real,
is that a real word?
Uh,
about the baby getting too big inside of
them and get stuck coming out of their
poster and just blow it all out.
If you've got a seven foot three dude,
imagine how big is fucking babies are.
If it's half his baby,
you know you got a 1520 pound
baby inside your hooker.
You know what?
I will say this though,
I'm not attracted to zoo work that I'm
not a talk track that a real tall checks,
I'm just,
you know,
and especially when they
get fucking ridiculous.
If a girl is six foot one,
usually they gotta be,
they gotta have really pretty faces and
that's usually their bodies start to get
out of whack.
You know what I mean?
It just like,
but I have looked at big tall ass
checks and when you see them in public,
the thoughts we'll race through my mind.
Like damn,
that'd be nice just to pump a load into
her and see what my baby would see,
what my boy would turn out like,
you know what I mean?
How proud would I be up that fucking kid?
You know what I mean?
He's six foot three and that's my son.
And you imagine he's six foot five and
that's my son and he's eating ass Todd
Duffy looking dog.
That's my son.
Does the Subbie cool dude.
How cool would that be?
Can you imagine?
That's what you look for in a girl.
That's how you,
who cares what she looks like post.
Give me a son.
Two conversation at the same,
can you imagine?
That's how you found girls.
That's like how you went to go date girls
just by looking at them as a mother to
a child,
like a super athlete like you all.
See that's what I'm,
that dude who Zulu member Zulu,
the guy who fought Hixon gracing,
he has this story about,
uh,
the way he described it was a large
Negro bus and that he knew that she would
make great babies for him.
So he found her and he described like,
look what he did,
like how we shot Loza tour to make,
uh,
to make a boy that he knew that the way
he was doing it was definitely to make a
boy and he had some method
and then Zulu came out.
Did I would pay fit?
Great Story.
I would pay 50 bucks right
now if you said I got the DVD,
the documentary of that,
I'll give you 50 bucks for that.
I would even go 75 bucks per article.
Europe,
your das a lot.
But God dammit,
I'll still pay for it.
That's an awesome story.
You matched how much of a
pain in the ass it must be.
If you're a kid and your dad was some
fighter and you're supposed to be a
fighter too.
You're like,
God damn,
really,
I can't just have fun.
I can't just go,
hang on.
No,
I got to go on a fight.
Oh Shit.
Or like you need to lose his son.
His son didn't really seem like
you want it to be doing that.
Right.
You know,
I mean it's,
it's almost like,
I mean,
you almost have to,
if your,
your dad is Zulu,
you know your dad is famous guy who
gotten a bare knuckle cage fight with
fucking Hixon Gracie back in the game.
Maybe he,
maybe he wasn't into any
kind of got just like,
you know what,
I,
I don't want to work a regular job.
I got a name I can actually fight.
But it didn't do Jujitsu though.
He was all right.
He was like a purple
belt back when he fought.
So yeah,
he was doing Jujitsu so in a weird
way Zulu like Jujitsu Beats Zulu,
but Zulu son was into Jujitsu.
That's pretty cool,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
Do you remember that?
Hixon Gracie footage for those who don't
know Hixon versus Zulu is one of the
very,
very first like no rules,
fights,
you know,
that was like,
what are they planned it out.
They had a whole arena full of people
in Brazil checking this out and a young
Hixon Gracie,
he was like 18 I think he was
a representative of Jujitsu,
fought this shy,
it's super athlete,
black dude named Zulu.
And his guys just yoked.
He just,
just slamming them and Hixon eventually
gets his back and strangle them and it's
one of those all time great videos where
people watch it like Jujitsu Gardens.
Back in the day it was like,
this is proof man.
This is proof.
Like,
look,
if you get good Jujitsu,
you can overcome a guide like this,
like and you're,
he's 18 it was like
a big fucking deal and the footage
is so bad but it looks cool.
It's like 50th generation.
All that footage.
It's dude taping it off via jazz.
Somehow it got the DVD and then a copy
and it already started off as terrible
footage.
Now it's like like silhouetted kind of.
It's like a yellow and
black and orange type thing,
but it classes.
One of the coolest things that I ever
got at a being famous was I got to have
dinner with Hixson.
Dot.
Tommy may want to close things out,
man.
I had dinner with Hickson and then we
went over his house and we watched fights
and he broke down what
dudes were doing wrong.
He was watching Mario Sperry fight and
coliseum and he was just talking about
space.
Who's talking about I give no space,
I give no space.
He was talking about,
she was just so like,
it's such an intense dude,
you know,
like he was talking about,
like his philosophy on
Jujutsu very simple.
We started zero and from zero we're
going to one and we're not going back to
zero.
And then from one we're going to
two from two to three to checkmate,
that's where we're going to go.
And I was like,
God damn,
you get the chills talking to him.
You're like,
I'm sitting here talking to
Hixon motherfucking Gracie
and he's given me like
some intense life philosophy
on how he strangles dudes.
You know,
he's like,
he's into it.
You know,
when we were watching all these fights,
he's breaking shit down and he watched
the Funai fight with him and Kunaki does
Hixon fights,
man.
God,
I wish there were more of them.
So annoying man.
So annoying that you don't get to see
the best suppose had representative ever
of Jujitsu and at the
time fighting those guys.
You know,
finding all mark Coleman's and you know,
all the fucking guys and everyone was
scared of Mark Carr and all that shit.
How fascinating would that have been?
Mad.
Yup.
Fuck.
That would've been awesome.
Damn.
That would freak me out.
It really would.
Um,
it would freak me out to sit
and hang out with Hixon Gracie.
He's cool as fuck.
That would freak me out.
He's a super nice guys.
His son is cool.
It's fun.
Nobody else in Jujitsu
that would freak me out,
like kicks in.
You know what I mean?
Marcella Garcia,
to me,
Marcella Garcia is the number one
Jujitsu guy that's ever lived.
I think Marcella Garcia is the
number one guy that's ever lived,
you know?
Uh,
but Hixon wood is the most,
uh,
mystical
and rock star ish.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
He's like,
motherfucker was incredible hulk.
You know what I mean?
You've shown the incredible hulk with
Ed Norton when Ed Norton is learning how
to calm and control himself.
Hixon Gracie slapping them in the face.
That's,
that's the man.
Yeah.
I would freak out
if,
uh,
if like me and Hickson would,
you're sitting there talking to Jujitsu.
I mean it's not out of the question.
That might happen in the future for sure.
It might.
It might not.
I would love it.
I would,
that would be a fucking dream of mine
to hang out and talk to you Jitsu and
break shit to the core of the
people who don't know the history.
Eddie Bravo tapped Hickson's
brother boiler and a Abu Dhabi 2003,
and there's a giant upset when Eddie was
a brown belt and he caught him with a
triangle.
So there's like,
is it perceived animosity
sometimes because of that,
but there's nothing exists.
You've never been anything but
respectful of any of those guys.
You know,
it's just,
there's a,
I know that there were trying to do some
sort of a rematch with you and Heuler,
but uh,
yeah,
I guess that was badly or going to
happen is a promoter called or emailed me
last October,
right.
October or November.
And it was a guy that
I've done privates for.
I know who is,
and um,
he's really high up in Jujitsu in
the Middle East in Abu Dhabi and um,
they're putting together,
they were putting together a Nogi
world championship in Abu Dhabi.
They never had a Nogi one.
They're doing geeky world
championships out there,
but the Nogi ones,
they wanted to have one in April.
And they asked me if,
if they wanted to have me
and Heuler as a supermatch,
but they never contacted him.
They told him,
this is what happened.
Then I emailed him back and I'm like,
you know me,
I'm down to rematch boiler anytime.
I've always been down.
I've never been the one denying it.
I want one more match.
I want to try it.